you may have heard someone over 50 say
something like Millennials are
extravagant and irresponsible they can't
save a pretty thing because they spent
all our money on iPhone apps an avocado
tow and then of course a millennial
respond with it's not our fault we can't
save anything you boomers left us a
broken economic system it seems like
this generational boxing match heats up
more and more every day with both sides
saying the other just doesn't get it
so who's right one thing's for sure
America's relationship with money has
changed a lot in the last several
decades when baby boomers were young
adults it was possible to support a
family and buy a house on one income
without a college degree today that
sounds about as realistic as a comeback
by Blockbuster Video there are many
reasons for this but mainly it's that
the cost of living has been increasing
over the last few decades much faster
than wages can keep up this is
especially true of three major expenses
housing health care and education and
you can see the results of that
inflation in many generational trends
the percentage of Millennials who own
homes is around 8 points lower than it
was for Gen Xers and baby boomers at the
same age Millennials tend to value city
life over suburbia more than previous
generations so it makes sense that
they're more likely to be renters but
it's wrong to assume that they don't
recognize the importance of home
ownership most Millennials say they want
to own a home some day it's just that
they have to wait longer to do it the
median home price now outweighs the
median income by so much that in many
places it can take ten years or more to
save up enough for a down payment we're
just now starting to see millennial
homeownership rise as people in their
30s have finally saved enough money and
paid off enough debt to think about
settling down but less than a third
managed to put down the recommended 20%
meaning higher mortgage payments and
longer loan terms almost half of
millennial homeowners expressed
something that buyer's remorse much more
than it may be astir nation's because
the costs including interest taxes
maintenance turn out to be higher than
they were expecting thanks to a changing
labor market and our eyes and freelance
work the percentage of Americans who
rely on employer-based health care has
gone from around 84% in 1980 to around
58% today unfortunately for Millennials
who now make up the largest segment of
the workforce
that coincides with an epic increase in
medical costs this has forced
Millennials to be frugal consumers when
it comes to health care services there
are more likely to research costs and
compare reviews of providers online and
they're more willing to use telemedicine
and walk-in clinics as cheaper
alternatives to visiting a hospital
they're also more likely to forego
health insurance altogether which as we
covered in a previous video is not
recommended seriously check it out and
then there's the big dark cloud hanging
over so many members of this generation
student debt tuition has skyrocketed in
the last 30 years and combined with a
competitive job market many young people
felt they had no choice but to take out
huge college loans in the hope that
someday someday they'd earn enough to
pay them back according to a 2017 survey
63 percent of Millennials reported
having over $10,000 in student debt and
more than one-third had over 30,000
older Millennials in their mid to late
30s had the double misfortune of
graduating just as the Great Recession
of 2008 is starting which led to
essentially a lost decade of low wages
and accumulating debt this burden
pressured many to delay big life
milestones like getting married having
kids or buying house today one in five
Millennials expects to die without ever
getting out of debt so yeah there's no
doubt that Millennials face some unique
historical challenges to achieving the
same level of financial health as older
generations however there are some
tendencies of this age group that aren't
making things any easier
for one thing it is true that
Millennials love to go out for the first
time in history Americans spend more
money on bars and restaurants than on
groceries the average millennial eats
out five times a week
almost half spend more money at bars and
restaurants than they put into savings
accounts over one-quarter spend more on
coffee than they say Millennials also
tend to value experiences over things
meaning they'd rather spend their money
on interesting food travel and music
than cars houses and are less willing to
work the same job for a lifetime
some people attribute this to social
media induced FOMO that drives young
people to stockpile shareable memories
like currency while others would say
it's a more spiritual reaction to an
overly materialistic society whatever
the cause attempts millenials away from
prioritizing long term investments like
IRAs and homeownership but if there is a
solid criticism to be made of
Millennials it's this even though they
are generally more educated than
previous generations they have the
lowest level of financial education in a
study by George Washington University
less than a quarter of Millennials could
demonstrate basic financial literacy
including economic concepts like
compound interest inflation and risk
diversification only 8% demonstrated
high financial literacy what's more
they're not asking for help only 27% had
ever sought professional advice for
saving and investment and only 12% for
debt management
this might explain why Millennials are
more likely to make illogical financial
decisions like racking up debt on a high
interest credit card while trying to pay
off a low interest student loan hello
this is really all part of the larger
economic shift 30 years ago employers
essentially held workers hands through
their financial lives a decent job could
last a lifetime and typically came with
health care and a company pension today
young workers are expected to figure it
out all for themselves and at no point
did anyone think of actually teaching
them how to do it
so our Millennials justifying their
completes for the most part yes but
justified or not no one else is likely
to help them out of this mess so they're
going to have to start educating
themselves now I don't as our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description if you would like to
support us on patreon what are some
other financial hardships that are
unique to your generation tell us about
it in the comments
you
[Music]